I take the trigger fingers from all my
prisoners that's less likely to shoot me
in the back
my business lock them up you are going
to hang for this what happened to you
see right now
[Music]
dead men strung to Your Wagon those men
threatened to rape my wife
mayor's gonna want to talk to you
[Music]
mayor Thomas where's he at Bishop's
mayor now
hello Roy I missed you by a day in
Galveston three young men are dead there
I didn't kill no one get your facts
straight friend
let's go not today I ain't asking I said
not today I've just been giving news
that my brother was murdered
I'm gonna give you one day in honor of
your brother don't break against me
get out of town they're gonna string you
up for killing the Man's brother we
gotta get the hell out of here you wanna
enjoy
[Music]
you win you walk out of here live lose
it's your judgment day
show them
[Applause]
oh you will pay for this mess you killed
man of the law and there ain't no
clemency for that
Reno's back
burrito you bring him to me dead or
alive Bishop's got 50 men securing that
in mind that's how you four gonna do you
can use your help
back on your horse and let's finish this
excited
Revenge
kill him kid